someone's kidnapped my wife I already  paid them your wife where is she she's  dead I pay them but they killed her  anyway why aren't you a cop them senior  private detective  unlicensed I do favors for people your  turn  they give me gifts you've dealt with  situations like this like this whoever  it was did your wife didn't just make  your name out of a hat I've been  following her know your schedule I  understand we have a new player in the  game  you want your money or you want a bit  looking behind you for the rest of your  worthless life  you know I could cut a little broken  tender back daddy a chunk at a time now  once we're in the van they're just body  parts  and not human how can I find them